well there is a in the primates there's
a a fairly consistent pattern of
dominance yielding more offspring and so
the dominant male in a in a boner chimp
group will have more sexual access to
the females in part because he will
drive away rivals and he's able to
because he's stronger or he's more
cunning and he he will have more
offspring and there are of course
legendary tales of Emperor's and kings
and dictators who've had many many wives
or mistresses or women anyway and they
they have more offspring so from the
point of view of the hard I of nature
having more offspring is good if you can
sustain the costs but the average human
being can have barely one or two or
three or four children and it's a
difficult responsibility to take care of
them sometime in Europe we shifted to
the kind of nuclear family model and
we've maybe we did that because of the
industrial system which requires that
people be mobile and able to move to
where the work is and then they go there
with their wife and children or their
husbands and children and then they take
care of them but what's what's involved
in raising children is of course an
immense set of endless responsibilities
and and tasks
many religious people actually wear
amulets on their body to indicate if
only to themselves that they're Catholic
that Jewish they're Muslims or whatever
and humans are group animals you can't
live alone
and we're not equipped to be alone
as a consequence whatever affiliation we
have we tend to celebrate and to assert
and so it's a mystery why a Catholic or
say to Christians Lutheran and Baptist
will be in disagreement about some
fundamental issues and in some cases as
with the Sunni and the Shia they'll
actually kill each other for reasons
which have to do with something that
happened hundreds and hundreds of years
ago nobody remembers why but the idea of
identity that's associated with religion
is sufficiently important to so many
people that they are prepared to get
punished incarcerated for their religion
because somehow religion becomes
associated with the essence of self and
it's a mystery if you will how that
happens but people will do things as you
suggested for religion that they
wouldn't do for anything else after all
of you're a holy warrior and you're
wanting to kill somebody because they're
not of your religion it's hard killing
people is difficult unless you can just
blast them with a big weapon but if you
have as in the early days of religious
wars where you have to actually go up to
somebody and cut their throat or beat
them up or do something that's hard work
and generally people do not want to be
killed and so they fight back and so
you've got quite a struggle going on
when all you're trying to do in your own
mind is perfecting the world for God or
you're gone it's a very interesting
question why that happens
it does seem that some religions are
somewhat more peaceful than others which
is in principle a good thing except that
they may then get over rot or overrun by
more truculent religions and that has
happened we've seen it repeatedly it
it's almost certain that some religions
are better than others in the sense of
providing a peace of mind a sense of
social comfort a sense of decency than
other religions one of the interesting
things about the Christian religion is
the notion of original sin or the
Catholics especially so that you're born
bad and you've got to kind of work off
your your badness through your lifecycle
that's a very interesting idea why that
should be and why that should have
worked but it has you have only to read
one of the most important scientific
texts on the subject James Joyce's
portrait of the artist as a young man
when he's confronted by the contrast
between his own sexuality and Roman
Catholicism in Ireland to see how
turbulent this whole thing is